[Musique]
voir les enfants un beauf
ou le seul tu es fort pressé ne rouille
j'espère que cette coquine de julio tas
a rendu mes lunettes à nicolas et appâts
problem of art show avec son lit boueux
hop hop hop hop hop hop hop hop hop
on
[Musique]
joue on avait que des noirs jeu trop
gentil ou sauver les meubles voici
encore une
copie beaucoup il me tue les gens droite
est l'une des très courts
dijon où es tu
cela drôle
bien
sûr
merci maman lui a dit se laver
votre maman enfin oui courage quand
lille on va être très propre
bravo à gilles cornichons valait quand
les gens ne doivent pas savons de toi
bien vite il est très fort à toi avec la
brosse lourd
la tradition
ça va salut nous
tu viens de te prendre une douche lui
mais avec un imperméable c'est plus
brutaux
enfin cornichons on entend par sa douche
avec train a perdu 1,6 ou est toujours
pas preneur et nicolas oui ça ne trouve
pas ça drôle du tout
prendre sa douche avec un an
il est malin cornichons google
l'accusant
de lunettes tu vois on les a mis dans sa
belle et huy où ce jeudi merci le zoo
faux
méchant venu je vais dormir de ma forêt
dont nos forums ben oui près de l'arbre
avec juliette a
pas mieux de nos amis non je teins la
lumière auto
salut licha
[Musique]
de nuit les petits qu
il a de curieuses
et cornichons c'est très agréable de
prendre une douche je suis bien de votre
avis pas trop petit par moments mais
j'ai récupéré mes lunettes avec apple
depuis le chef bonne nuit des enfants ne
faites pas comme cornichons car vous
feriez de la peine à votre maman
allez vite vous coucher du fait de
pauvres
[Musique]